before we begin
with our second installment here i think
another congratulations
is in order that we have reached the
second
week of ramadan alhamdulillah
this is something that we praise allah
for
fervently and vehemently
it's such a blessing to for an
individual to experience such a blessed
month
and to be part of it and not only that
but
those who are listening to me now and
myself included
we are spending our time we're spending
our day right now
in ramadan studying the words of allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala
and that's exactly what ramadan is about
that is the spirit of ramadan when we
look at ramadan
as a side note here before we get into
the crux of what we're going to speak
about today
when we look at ramadan we see that it
all revolves around the quran
that's what ramadan really is it's kind
of a homage
it's a month of commemoration of the
quran
of an additional portion of focus
on the quran why is that well
we fast during the day to purify our
hearts to purify our minds to purify our
bodies to purify our souls
and then we stand at night and we recite
the quran
and this was the month that allah
subhanahu ta'ala chose
for the quran to be revealed in
ramadan
and we are encouraged to recite the
quran
and review the quran and study the quran
it all revolves around the quran
and that's really what this month is
about and that's what we're trying to do
here
we're attempting to sit and
discuss a few verses of the book of
allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala that hopefully
we may gain guidance and we may gain
wisdom
from these words that we are going to be
discussing today
insha'allah before we continue i do want
to mention there is a narration
that's floating around and
many people will be shocked about this
narration to hear
that it's actually an inauthentic
narration
it's mentioned that the first
month the first third of ramadan
is mercy and the second third of ramadan
is forgiveness and the third
and final third of ramadan
is
emancipation from the hellfire
and this narration is not authentic it's
not the words of the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam
it is something that is very common and
we hear a lot of people mention
but we should be happy actually that
this narration
is inauthentic because really all of
ramadan
is forgiveness and all of ramadan
is mercy and all of ramadan
is emancipation from the hell fire
and the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
in
he said that every night allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala has designated
certain individuals that he has freed
and emancipated from the hellfire every
single night of ramadan
so we should be happy this is this is
not an authentic narration
rather every week
and every third and every day
and night of ramadan is mercy and every
day and night
of ramadan is forgiveness and every day
and night
of ramadan is
emancipation and freedom from the
hellfire and escape
from the hellfire
today inshallah ta'ala we are going to
be discussing suratul cafe roon
suratul kaffiroon is referred to by the
scholars of islam
as the second surah of ichlas
we mentioned before in our previous
installment in this
series here that
taheed is of two
categories two types when we want to
speak about the tahiti of allah the
oneness of allah
we say that the oneness of allah
traditionally
is categorized into two categories
where did this categorization come from
it didn't come from the mind of any
particular individual
it didn't come from any particular
person
when we read through the quran we read
through the sunnah of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
these things become apparent
this pattern begins to manifest itself
this is what the scholars of islam call
well is the qra at the tab
is when you read through a lot of the
quran and a lot of the sunnah
and a certain pattern became becomes
apparent to you
this pattern is called
and this is actually a type of evidence
in the sky in the science of us
now the science of us which is the
hermeneutics of filk
of understanding jurisprudence
now with regards to
the two types of toheid
this is a pattern which has been noticed
by the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
by the companions by the scholars of
tafsir
that tahid is categorized into two types
there is tahid which takes place in
knowledge
and there is tahid which takes place in
the heart and
actions this is what is to hate
when i say the tawheed of allah the
worship of allah
the oneness of allah i am speaking about
not only am i believing
in the oneness of allah but i am
actually
implementing that belief in the oneness
of allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
because even if i believe that allah is
the only one who created
he's the only creator if i believe that
allah is the only creator
yet i worship another along with him
i am no longer a person of tohit that is
how that works
if you notice what the people of hud
said to him
right the people of ayad
they said to hud
did you are you trying to tell us that
you came to us to deliver a message that
we should worship allah
alone they worshipped allah
they believed that allah was the only
creator but they worshipped
others along with allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala
these others that they worshipped along
with allah they believed were
saints and people that were close to
allah that
could take their problems to allah for
them
and allah subhanahu wa ta'ala would
honor their request on his behalf
interceders this is what
sheikh actually is this is what it that
this is its essence
the essence of the worship of other than
allah is not the belief
that there are more than one creator
that is not the that is not the essence
of the essence of sheikh
the essence of shirk is not to believe
that there
is more than one creator the essence of
polytheism idolatry
the worship of other than allah is to
believe that
others are worthy of worship aside from
allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
the belief or the act of doing so this
is what real
polytheism is allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
explains this to us
he says
if you were to ask them he's speaking to
the prophet muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
if you were to ask them who's them if
you were to ask
abuja and abu lahab and the most
bitter enemies of yours those who are
most
fervent opponents
of the religion of the prophet muhammad
sallallahu
alaihi wasallam if you were to ask them
who has created the heavens and the
earth
they would reply allah allah is the
creator obviously
but when he would say then worship only
allah that's when they say let
are you saying that we should we should
not worship what our our
ancestors worshipped that's a different
thing
and so it's important for us to
understand this concept
just because a person believes that
allah is the only creator that alone
does not
enter a person into islam a person has
to believe
that allah is the only creator and he
has to
worship only allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
in order to be a muslim that is what it
is
if we look at all of the other religions
even hinduism
hinduism has more than 20
million different gods that they worship
20 million right
they have so many that they have lost
count of how many they have
if we were to look at that and we were
to look at the
original scriptures of hinduism
and we were to ask truly knowledgeable
hindus they will all tell you that
no the original god is one
the god head whether they call him
krishna or they call him brahman
or whatever it is that they call the god
head
and all of these other things that they
worship are either saints or
manifestations of that
of that same one god and so
this is exactly what shirk is allah
tells us in the quran
that sheikh is because
they are worshipping these idols so that
these idols will draw them closer to
allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
so they say so he said subhanahu ta'ala
is
and those who worship other than allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala
those who worship other than allah
subhanahu wa'ta'ala at the beginning of
surah
those who worship other than allah they
claim
the only reason we are worshipping these
saints or these idols
is so that they can draw us nearer to
allah subhanahu
this is the way they had it figured out
they said look
if there's a king you can't just go
straight to the king and talk to him
that's not how it works the way it works
is the king has ambassadors and he has
courtiers and he has so forth and you
get to know one of them and you get in
real good and tight with one of them and
you do favors for them and you're
friends with them and you say hey when
you speak to the king
tell the king to give me such and such
or put in a good word for me that's the
whole idea
modern catholicism is the exact same
thing it's the worship of saints
the idea that we will worship a
particular saint
this saint will take to god our prayers
for us and he will forgive us
because of the saints not because of us
we're not worthy of that forgiveness
as if allah subhanahu wa ta'ala cannot
forgive on his own
that he needs others to intercede on
behalf of his creation
and this is what surat in kafir is all
about
it's not enough just to believe that
allah is one
in his actions in his names and his
attributes
but also that we worship only allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala alone without any
partners
and so now that we know that this is the
theme of the chapter
let's get into the individual minutiae
and the verses
of the chapter allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
says
which we spoke about last week he says
say o disbelievers
i do not worship what it is you all
worship
nor will you nor will i ever worship
what you worship
nor will you ever worship what i worship
to you your deeds and actions
and to me my deeds and my actions
now let's try to break this down a
little bit
and unpack this chapter
allah subhanahu wa ta'ala begins the
chapter with say
and that is that each individual
is to say this he's to say this with his
actions
he's to say this with his heart he's to
say this with
when he is proclaiming his religion
he is to say
o those who are disbelievers
meaning those who are not upon the
religion of the prophet muhammad
sallallahu
alaihi wasallam now some people will say
well what do you mean they're
disbelievers they believe in god yes
mere belief in god does not make a
person a muslim
it is belief in god in the way that
allah subhanahu wa ta'ala has commanded
and believe in the prophet muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
and worshiping god alone without any
partners
that is what makes a person a muslim
not just belief in god belief in god
alone does not
enter a person into paradise most of
humanity
historically and currently believe in
god
believe in a higher force a higher power
they call it whatever it is they want to
call it
however this on its own
is not enough to make a person a muslim
a muslim is someone who not only
believes in allah subhanahu wa
but he worships allah alone without any
partners
and he worships him only in the way that
allah has commanded through his prophet
and messenger muhammad sallallahu alaihi
he says i do not worship that which you
all worship
of idols of saints of the moon the stars
whatever it is that people worship
other than allah and
and this is very interesting right here
and we will dwell upon this verse for a
moment
nor do you all worship what i worship
meaning you all do not worship allah
subhanahu wa'ta'ala
but the people of quraish did worship
allah
and it's mentioned in the quran that
they used to worship allah subhanahu wa
however that warship is considered
invalid why because it's not
based until heat i'll give you an
example
let's say a person comes stands for
prayer
and makes the best most beautiful prayer
that you have ever
seen recites the entire quran in his
prayer
to perfection right the rukur is perfect
the sujud is perfect the recitation is
perfect
everything is great however
this person does not have wudu they
don't make wudu
they they made the salah they recited
the quran
they did everything but they did not
make wudu
would we consider this salah
the answer is no this is not salah this
person has not prayed
even if he does it for five days
straight he has not prayed
the same thing let's say a person fast
and they say you know what i'm going to
be busy in ramadan so i'm going to fast
in the month of sha
ben right so they fast the perfect
fasting they only fast it outside of the
time of ramadan would we consider this
fasting the month of ramadan
absolutely not or let's say a person
goes for hajj
and does all of the monastic of hajj
does all of the rites of hajj perfectly
but they do it outside of the of the
time of hajj
would we consider this person to have
fulfilled the obligation of hajj
the answer is no this hajj is invalid
why because they have not provided
the condition for hajj
for fasting for salah the condition for
salah
is if you do not have wudu you do not
have salah
because salah is conditionable is
conditioned
by wudhu it is qualified by will
if you do not have wudu you do not have
salah
the same thing if you do not have to
heed
you do not have worship you have not
worshipped allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
and this is why shirk is so dangerous
because if a person worships other than
allah along with him
his worship of allah is invalid
we have a narration which is collected
by an imam muslim on the authority of
abi hurairah
in which the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said that
he said i am least in need
of a partner anyone who does
any action and associates a partner with
me
along with me in that worship
i will forsake him and i will forsake
his shirk his his worship that is that
worship
is invalid because another has been
associated with allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala in it
we will speak about this topic more
as we continue on in this series insha
allah
he then reiterates this he says
nor will i ever worship what you
all worship
nor will you all ever worship what i
worship meaning as long as you remain
upon what you are
upon
and the reason that this verse these
verses were revealed
as a rahimahullah mentions in his book
yes he mentions that
the mushrikeen of quraish they came to
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
and they said look let's let's make a
deal okay
how about we try each other's religions
out you worship our gods for one year
and we'll worship your god for one year
and we'll see which one is better which
we will see which one fares out better
or we'll continue to do this and
everybody get along
and so allah subhanahu wa ta'ala sent
down this response
right at the end he says
which is often oftentimes translated as
to you
your religion and to me mine and that is
not a correct translation
aden in the arabic language in the quran
in this context refers to actions
right what he is saying is
meaning to you your actions
and to me my actions you all
are responsible for your actions and i
am responsible for my actions
it's not religion he's not saying to
them
look all road all roads lead to rome
you guys worship whoever you want and
i'll worship whoever i want
and god will take care of it at the end
when we all meet as they say as some
people say
no this is not what the prophet
sallallahu alaihi
was commanded to have said he was
commanded to say
to you your actions and to me my
actions and this is a repeated theme
throughout the quran to you
your actions to me my actions
i am innocent of what it is that you do
and you
all are innocent of what it is that i do
if you disbelieve in me
we ask allah subhanahu wa ta'ala to
benefit us from what we have heard
to make us of those who hear the truth
have the
distinction and the criterion to
recognize it when we see it
and when we hear it to have the audacity
and bravery to follow that truth
and have the honor and nobility to die
for and upon that truth
is